hey this is presh talwalkar
two line segments meet at a right angle
in the corner construct a circle that's
tangent to each of the line segments
then construct an identical circle above
this first circle so it's tangent to the
first circle and change it to the left
line segment
then construct a third circle that's
also identical to the first circle and
make this third circle tangent to the
first circle and change it to the bottom
line segment
now construct a fourth circle that's
tangent to both line segments and
tangent to the second and third circles
if the radius of this large circle is
equal to 1
what is the radius of each small circle
i thank umesh for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
recall if two circles are tangent their
centers and the tangent point are
collinear
that's because the tangent line through
t will be perpendicular to the radius a
t
and the tangent line through t will also
be perpendicular to the radius bt
therefore atb is a straight line segment
that's true for both externally and
internally tangent circles
now let's solve the problem
to make things easier to see let's zoom
on the bottom left corner
construct the center of each circle
the large circle has a radius that's
equal to one
suppose the radius of each small circle
has length equal to r
then if we construct this line segment
it will span
three radius lengths so its length will
be equal to three r
now construct the following vertical
radius of the large circle
it will be perpendicular to the
horizontal line segment
now connect the center of the third
circle and make a horizontal to this
vertical radius
we've constructed a rectangle
therefore we can compute the following
length
the purple and peach line segments
together have a length equal to 1
therefore the peach line segment has a
length equal to 1 minus 3r
next the following length will be equal
to r
which means this length will be equal to
one minus r
from here connect the center of the
large circle to the center of the third
circle
one length will be equal to one
and the other length will be equal to r
we can now focus on the following right
triangle
we know the length of each of its sides
one leg is equal to one minus r the
other leg is equal to one minus three r
and the hypotenuse is equal to one plus
r
since we have a right triangle
here we go again
we have the quantity one minus three r
squared plus the quantity one minus r
squared is equal to the quantity one
plus r squared
we can expand each binomial and then
collect like terms
we have a quadratic equation
this is easily factorable
one factor will be nine r minus nine and
the other factor will be r minus one
over nine
this gives the two solutions that r is
equal to 1 and r is equal to 1 over 9.
but recalling that the radius of the big
circle is equal to 1 we can eliminate
the solution that r is equal to 1
because we know the radius of each small
circle will be less than the radius of
the big circle
therefore the radius of each small
circle is equal to one over nine
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube
see you next episode of mind your
decisions where we solve the world's
problems one video at a time
you